الأجنبية
[موسيقى]
القدرة على الحصول على
شهادة الهولوغرافيك عن بعد هي ببساطة
الأحدث في المغامرة المستمرة حول كيفية
استخدام التكنولوجيا
وكيفية تقديم المشورة للقضاة والمحامين
والإداريين والمحامين والطلاب
حول هذا الموضوع وكيف نأمل في تحسين
المهن القانونية
الأجنبية
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى  ]
[موسيقى]
النظام القانوني نولي قدرًا كبيرًا من
الأهمية لما يسمى
دليل السلوك الذي يعني قدرة
القاضي أو المحلف على تحديد ما إذا كان
الشاهد ، على سبيل المثال ، يقول
الحقيقة كليًا أو جزئيًا ، من
الصعب فعلاً فعل ذلك  أنه في أحد
تطبيقات مؤتمرات الفيديو القياسية ، يتيح لك ذلك إلى حد
كبير القيام بما كنت ستفعله بالضبط إذا
كان هذا الشخص موجودًا في الغرفة
[موسيقى] [
تصفيق] [
موسيقى]
أجنبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]